a
[Música]
[Aplausos]
te quiero preguntar a ti cuando prenden
un coche que es lo primero que tienes
que hacer para que pueda empezar avanzar
tener la llave b a cuándo plan es un
coche que es lo primero que hay hacer a
acelerar antes de acelerar tú me podrías
decir que se tiene que hacer
dentro del coche
y tener un coche ya teniendo el coche ya
entrando lo principal que se tiene que
hacer cuando uno tiene realmente un
coche para empezar a avanzar hay que
pisar el freno y sinceramente y algo que
creo que a todos nos sucedió es que
justamente antes de esta etapa del
cobijo de todos pensábamos que vivíamos
en un ida y vuelta sin freno cada uno de
nosotros sentíamos que nada nos detenían
nada no importaba si nos ponían tres
eventos en un mismo fin de semana íbamos
a estar en los tres y prácticamente lo
que sucedió es que no entendíamos que
había un freno personalmente a mí me
sucedió justamente algo donde era todo
ficticio mi vida era un sueño eventos de
estar para aquí para acá en movimiento
conociendo contacto contacto y no había
un freno de decir hacia dónde voy y es
la realidad de lo que vivía antes de
todo esta etapa del cobismo y justamente
fue en ese momento donde me di cuenta
que estábamos llevando una vida donde
uno de nuestros maestros más grandes que
más grandes que tengo es un gran mentor
le dicen así yo también puse esa cara
cuando me dijeron el nombre de la
primera vez y lo más increíble de él es
que él dice que cuando la gente está
caminando estaba corriendo en 2019
pasadas y le preguntaban adónde cordes
dice no lo sé dice quién te persigue
nadie es ese tema de iu porque estás
corriendo no tengo tiempo para responder
esa era la mentalidad en la que vivíamos
cada día sin realmente entender hacia
dónde íbamos y de pronto
en un colapso que ese colapso muchas
personas lo llaman la peor etapa de su
vida nos llama la mejor pero creo que
todos podemos coincidir que nos empujó a
un reto superior del que esperábamos de
pronto uno no puede salir de tu casa no
vas a ver a tus amigos se acabaron las
universidades se acaban las festividades
ya como no es real esto acaba en dos
semanas y ya de pronto no y esto sigue
llevamos un año y cada uno nosotros
seguimos teniendo tecnológicas y lo más
increíble es que hay una frase que dice
la libertad sin dirección es otro tipo
de esclavitud y eso es algo espectacular
porque porque uno que es libre y no sabe
hacia dónde va a seguir esclavo y eso es
lo que estaba como estábamos viviendo y
justamente lo que sucedió es que una
cosa más pequeña que un grano de sal
prácticamente el kobe 19 llegó a parar a
un un planeta tierra aunque con una
enseñanza de decir aquí todos somos
vulnerables y cuando entendemos que no
controlamos la situación y es muy duro
entender que vivíamos en un mundo donde
no te gusta tu nariz de la ópera no te
guste el pelo que tienes te lo pintas no
te gusta cómo te ves físicamente te
operas y prácticamente esto nos dijo así
te tienes que quedar entonces justamente
y es algo muy duro a mí lo que me en
cuenta en este en esta pausa fue que
perdí mi visión por llegar a mi ambición
que prácticamente que es eso mi meta era
llegar a ser la estrella y me olvidé que
lo más importante para mí era defender
mi causa es una frase que menciona a mí
que siempre que me toca una plática me
pongo muy emotivo y puede ser que llore
ahorita con ustedes porque me emociono y
les quiero transmitir esto de corazón
pero cuando uno lucha por lo que tiene
enfrente lo recordarán por lo que tiene
atrás y en esa época antes del gobierno
yo estaba luchando por lo que tenía
atrás que era mi nombre quería mostrar
a enseñar que podía y esta etapa a mí me
siento y me dijo tranquilo no vas a
ningún lado aquí hay que empezar a
replantear las penas y es justamente
este tema donde todos creo que tuvimos
la oportunidad y a mí me tocó ver una
frase que decía sí señor dame la
serenidad para aceptar lo que no puedo
cambiar más que nada valorar valor para
cambiar lo que sí puedo y sabiduría para
distinguir la diferencia y cuando me
acuerdo que me senté y me di la
oportunidad de hacer eso dije este
sentimiento nunca lo he vivido y que fue
ese sentimiento algo que en hebreo se
llama itb o de ducto imagina de esa
forma de las letras o la ley la al revés
es el idioma hebreo ésta lo quisimos
pero eso es y que sí tuvo debut es un
aislamiento donde prácticamente provocas
entre una oración y una meditación y
entras en conciencia se dice que todos
los antiguos líderes de los diferentes
pueblos eran pastores alguien como
moisés alguien como el rey david
y pronto eso es algo súper importante
todos ellos porque eran pastores porque
tenían un tiempo para para aislarse y
estar en sus pensamientos
si todavía no me entienden lo van a
entender con esta imagen qué pasa en la
película del región
literalmente llega un punto donde simba
está tan perdido en el gozo con timón
con tumba
hakuna matata la vida que estábamos no
importa no tienes de qué preocuparte eso
era la vida que teníamos y de pronto qué
pasa con el rey león' que le dice muy
falsa simba le dice al fulgor en uruguay
subió a poco ahora en mí te olvides de
quién eras tú y por eso te olvidas de mí
y creo que es algo que nos sucedió a
todos que perdimos la esencia de lo que
realmente somos y prácticamente en este
espacio decir y tú redoute que es
aislamiento a mí me tocó vivir algo
igual en ese momento si te adiós le dije
existes necesito verte necesito hablar
contigo estoy muy preocupado no sé a
dónde voy no sé lo que quiero todo mi
año estaba dirigido a hacer eventos
hacer fiestas y de pronto nada
y me dio una cita con dios y
prácticamente no digo que fue el mismo
momento que simba tuvo pero si les puedo
decir que fue un acercamiento muy
profundo donde en ese momento me di
cuenta que prácticamente me contaron
hace poco una historia increíble había
un granjero precioso divino cuidaba a
sus gallinas a sus vacas y de pronto
tenía un caballo que era ese caballo
blanco le decían espíritu ese iba
hecho la raya a todos los levantaba y de
pronto ese caballo en uno de esos hoyos
que había por las granjas se cae el
granjero empieza a ver al caballo y
empieza a relinchar y empieza y el
granjero se empieza a poner tan nervioso
que dice hay que llamar a una grúa que
saquen al caballo de pronto llegan chica
en la grúa dicen para llegar a la ciudad
es mucho más caro que lo que cuesta tu
granja traer un agro aquí todos los
granjeros que les sugieren en tierra y
que dice él lo acepto empieza a agarrar
tierra y le empiezan a tirar tierra al
caballo en ese momento el granjero dijo
yo ya me voy porque no puedo ver sufrir
a mi a mi caballo le echan la tierra al
caballo se sacude se pasa para acá le
echa en la tierra se sacude y se pasa
para acá y empieza a subida del hoyo y
sale porque se limpio lo que esa tierra
que le caían y me di cuenta que estaba
lleno de tierra y lo único que tenía que
empezar a hacer es acudir de esa tierra
y salir adelante con eso prácticamente
empecé a ver las noticias y dije sí está
muy fuerte lo que está sucediendo pero
también
estamos siendo más empáticos también
está viendo más ayuda de repente en
venecia ya se ve el agua cristalina de
pronto los animales silvestres y
empiezan a salir en los bosques y
empezamos a valorar lo que antes no
valoraba un tiempo en familia una mesa
los primos que en facetime con ellos
eran lo máximo cuando podíamos comer con
ellos cada semana y me valorábamos nada
ver a mis abuelitos después de tres
meses de perder a mi abuelita y después
ir con mis otros abuelitos era un
sentimiento realmente que no teníamos el
valor y justamente me di cuenta que en
las crisis y justo me salió esto en la
lectura no date la oportunidad de leer
qué empresas se crearon durante las
crisis y tú dirías como no quién no pues
bueno conozco después de la recesión de
los fines de la década de 1970 united
united airlines procter gamble que son
empresas que dicen no puede ser pero si
se crearon a través de una crisis que
genera una oportunidad y es por eso que
dicen que hay una cámara que es uno de
los libros más profundos de la música
por así decirlo judía que hay varios
tomos y uno de ellos dice para construir
te como persona y dejar huella en el
mundo tienes que hacer tres cosas número
uno tener un hijo número dos plantar un
árbol y número tres escribir un libro
demi la cara no es mi hija es mi sobrina
solo que vi esa foto tierna y pensé que
estaba bonito con él entonces justamente
dije un hijo ahorita no no está en mis
planes plantar un árbol gracias a dios
de niño de plantado por escribir un
libro eso nunca lo he hecho y un libro
al final se puede traducir a una semilla
porque una semilla se les puede si una
semilla de un árbol un árbol da un fruto
un fruto un producto un producto en
juego un jugo una una compañía una
compañía una sociedad una sociedad una
ciudad una ciudad un país un país un
continente y un continente del mundo
todo empieza de una semilla
y prácticamente surgió una idea
donde hablando con las diferentes
fundaciones que tenemos en libro nos
dicen no hay manera que sobrevivamos
esto todos los apoyos están yendo
prácticamente a doctores hospitales
nadie está viendo que los índices de
violencia en mujer están subiendo que
todos los diferentes hospitales que
tienen niños con cáncer moviendo a niños
de hospitales públicos de un lugar a
otro y nadie se entera de nada y nadie
está apoyando entonces cómo vamos a
hacer para poder ayudar a las
fundaciones que llevan 10 15 ó 25 años
trabajando en méxico defendiendo causas
que no podemos perder de vista y
justamente la idea que surgió fue decir
qué pasaría si escribimos un libro que
sea una herramienta para que ellos la
puedan vender un libro que pueda porque
bueno tienen torneos de golf o no tienen
ganas no tienen su carrera entonces
prácticamente la inr a escribir un libro
que lo puedan vender y fue esta idea
decir que estarán pensando las
celebridades que estaba pensando en los
empresarios los deportistas y justamente
de pronto empezó una lucha titánica por
lograr un sueño
y ese sueño se puede traducir con
esfuerzo con valentía con muchas
cualidades pero con mucha unión que eso
es lo que más nos sorprende todo empezó
por bajar dos preguntas mandárselas a
kate del castillo y alista aparicio de
pronto después de tres días a ver por
esos momentos difíciles que ha hecho que
nuestra habitación pues en la vida el
amor esté de mi familia sin duda es del
gatillo manda su voice loud de sus tres
respuestas de sus dos respuestas de
repente rafa márquez de repente alberto
torrado eduardo tricio y se empiezan a
juntar y empezamos a buscar gente y
empezamos y todo para una realidad que
prácticamente fue decir hay que unir a
las voces más emblemáticas de méxico oye
pero cómo vas a juntar a la lista
aparicio con juán basurita con carlos
loret de mola todo se puede cuando uno
tiene la voluntad de perseguir algo más
grande que él mismo y justamente surgió
esto que lo tenemos aquí y esto no es un
libro es esto es la respuesta al
gobierno
de que hay unión y que en méxico y que
en el mundo si se puede cuando uno tiene
la voluntad de dar por los demás y decir
yo no me quedo en mi lugar parado
enfriando me no yo con todo lo que me ha
tocado vivir voy sobre eso y es la
respuesta que es lo más importante esta
respuesta que más allá de que el
contenido está especial esto en menos de
26 días ha generado un impacto más de 2
millones de personas de beneficiados y
generando más de un millón 500 mil pesos
en donación a las fundaciones eso es a
mí lo que me hace despertarme cada día
eso es lo que yo veo positivo gracias
comida porque tú me empujas de hacer
esto y porque sin ti no estoy acá y es
por eso que hoy los invito a que se den
cuenta que cada día y cada crisis es una
oportunidad para decir voy con todo
porque porque siempre lo digo no hay que
tenerle miedo a nada más aún más que una
cosa al que no tiene miedo porque cuando
pensamos en esa persona que estrelló el
nine eleven como llegó al aeropuerto
quítate voy voy a ir a estrellar lo y
fue y estrelló y toda su energía lo lo
encausó al mal qué pasaría si nosotros
cada mañana nos despertamos y si nos
vamos por algo más grande que nosotros
mismos ese es el sentimiento real que
tenemos que tener y prácticamente eso es
lo que puedo lo que puedo llevarme esto
que son seis puntos más bien ocho que a
mí me han dejado todo el número uno es
para avanzar hay que pisar el freno
recuerden que muchas veces los límites
son lo que nos llevan a otro extremo
prácticamente el ego es el enemigo lo
que mencionábamos de decir si vas a
jugar por lo de adelante te van a
recordar por lo de atrás y este tema de
no seas esclavo de tu propia libertad
y me emociono y voy a llorar al final
así que prepárense pero bueno en los
detalles más simples están las las
alegrías más grandes no les puedo
describir el sentimiento que tengo de
ver una tarde a mi papá sentado junto a
mí cuando era algo imposible antes del
cobijo ver y poder salir a caminar y
decir que espacio y qué momento tan
profundo y tan tan delicioso y
prácticamente es la desconexión es la
clave y es la llave para llegar a la
conexión quieres entrar con tu esencia
como persona lo que mencionamos de iu
producto aislante y entra en ti y
prácticamente sacude la tierra y
levántate juega por lo que tienes
delante y más que nada recuerda que el
obstáculo es el camino y la unión hace
la fuerza no hay que tener miedo hay que
vivir con fe gracias le agradezco a dios
por darme lo podría seguir cada paso de
mi vida no estoy aquí por mi mérito
estoy aquí por ejemplo porque él me ha
guiado porque él me ha cuidado y me ha
dicho
estoy contigo y para mí esa es la vida
el saber que lo que tú tienes que hacer
cada mañana es despertarte y ser un
héroe para alguien más porque el éxito
es saber que alguien vive más feliz
porque tú existes el cob y le agradezco
a ti por toda la bendición que la
estrella mi vida se llama propósito y
con eso
hay que dar amor gratuito le agradezco
también a carla por el apoyo y porque
juntos estamos muy cerca de estar muy
lejos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah